hey everyone this is kevin from
thechesswebsite.com and today we're
going to be going over the lure trap in
the alakine defense last video we did a
trap
as black in the alkine defense this is
going to be
from white's perspective so it starts
out with pawnee 4
knight 2 f 6 and the most common play
which white's going to play is
pawn 2 e5 knight comes down here to
d5 and then white has lots of different
options you could see things pawn to d4
you could immediately push up here with
c4 attacking the knight here
or many times what i like to play is
knight to
f3 usually your opponent is going to
play d6 this is the most
common line it attacks this pawn right
here on e5
opens up for the light square bish
should we get involved into the game
just a lot of things going for black by
playing this
now white can continue with d4
defending this pawn right here on e5
just solidifying the pawn chain in the
center of the board
as well and then bishop to g4 you could
see
bishop to f5 bishop to g4 pinning down
the knight is pretty common as well
bishop here to e2 stopping that
pin from happening pawn takes here on e5
and then the knight takes here on e5 i
think this is just much better than the
pawn taking here
because after knight two c6 attacking
the pawn
this knight here on f3 is defending it
but this bishop can just take the knight
here on f3 and it's just kind of awkward
so
best play i think is just take here on
e5
with the knight after the bishop takes
queen takes here on
e2 so with any chest
opening in this case we're playing the
alakina defense
it's always important to understand
where your opponent can go look at
different variations and see
if they make a mistake how can you
capitalize and so this is something in
the lore trap where your opponent may
not make this mistake but if it is i get
asked all the time like hey
my my opponent did something i did not
understand what they were doing
how can i actually turn that into a
victory so this is going to be one
example
of what happens if your opponent thinks
they have something where in reality
we're going to take advantage of that
and so you have this pawn here on
d4 and so they could look at and say how
do i actually attack this pawn here on
d4 one way would be to play
knight to b6 there's now a discovered
attack with the queen coming down
to d4 this would be a very strong move
take this pawn here on a d4 get the
strongest piece on the board and the
center of the action here but
we don't really need to worry about that
white can just continue with the move
castle on the king side and the reason
for that is this
is a trap because we don't mind if our
opponent takes this pawn
it is definitely a poison pawn because
if they take the pawn here on d4
then we have the move rook to d1
and all is lost so let's take a look at
some of the ways that they could
try to play from here what's nice is
this knight here on e5
or yeah e5 is blocking off some of the
squares that the queen would want to go
to so it can't
stay along this d file it's just going
to die to this rook here and so really
we're just looking at this fourth rank
here as far as where the queen can go
and it can't come to b or c4
or g4 that's just going to die to the
knight here
and so let's let's take a look at queen
2 h4
well white now has the move bishop to
g5 and if they take well now white has
the sacrifice here rook
2 d8 the king has to take and then
knight two
f seven king two e8 and then
the knight takes the queen here on
g5 and this should be a pretty easy
victory for whitetail you know knight
two
c6 knight here to e6 this is stopping
black you cannot castle through a check
so this square here on
d8 is under attack by the knight so the
king can't go anywhere it's also
threatening this move
knight takes here on c7 the queen
anytime can come up here to h5
attack knight two c3 get the rook
involved
as well and you can see it's pretty
awkward from black standpoint
uh the rook here on h8 how does it
really get involved into the game
this bishop here on f8 it can't go
anywhere
with this pawn moving so it's going to
be looking to push something like
pawn to uh g6
but then it's just pretty awkward as far
as how black gets out of this mess so
uh that is kind of the trap in a
nutshell
there's other variations that black can
play you know they don't have to take
that bishop there on g5 they could just
say you know queen
to b4 okay well now we have the move
queen to f3 and this is threatening
queen coming up here to
f7 and this would be checkmate and no
it does not stop it if they play pawn to
f6 it looks
like an extremely strong move it not
only stops the threat
immediately of queen takes here on f7
but it also forks
both of these squares here on e5
and g5 unfortunately that does lose to
queen to h5
check remember the king cannot come to
the d-file because it is under attack
from this rook here on
d1 so the only move they can play is
pawn to g6 to stop it
but then knight takes on g6 and things
are
all but lost you know they can't take
with their pawn because that would just
be checkmate and so there's just no
other moves that they can really make
here as soon as the knight moves
anywhere
if it takes up here on h8 um then
there's going to be a discovered attack
with the queen and black's just going to
lose
too much of material or they're going to
end up losing the entire game
so that was if they move to queen to h4
then we play bishop
g5 what if they play something else
maybe they play queen to
c5 okay well now we can play the move
pawn to b4
essentially forcing them to come to b4
there's just no
other squares they can go to it comes to
b5 we take it with our queen
can't come to a5 i'm just going to take
it with our pawn
remember can't stay on this d file
it's going to just take from our rook
here so pretty much have to take the
pawn
and then white has the move queen to f3
this is attacking this same square here
on
f7 it's also attacking the square here
on b7
although white's typically not going to
be taking this pawn on b7 but it is
another
threat that they have and we already
have talked about if they play that pawn
to f6 move it's the same threat as
before
queen two h5 pawn to g6 knight takes
here on a g6 so
that option is not going to work now
they could try other stuff maybe knight
to
a d7 here and says okay i need my king
to have another outlet so if we play
queen takes here on f7
check now they can play king 2 d8 but
then
bishop 2 f4 you can see white's getting
all their material involved into the
game
they can get their knight involved into
the game now they can set up with
queen to e6 things get pretty difficult
from black here
neither of their rooks are going to be
involved into the game this bishop here
on f8 is not going to be involved into
the game the king is in the center
has no pawns in front of it black is
definitely going to
fall in this position if we come back
and say
okay what if it doesn't come to c5 what
if they just immediately come to b4
well as you guessed it we didn't even
have to sacrifice a pawn coming up here
we can just play queen to f3 same thing
even if they come all the way to a4
we're gonna be playing queen
to f3 with that threat of queen takes
f7 if they ever do move then we're just
gonna be playing that queen two h5
forcing them to come here and then
taking with our knight here on
g6 so that is the lure trap and that's
what happens if your opponent feels like
hey let's figure out how we can because
this is a pretty normal setup an alakan
defense and so
if they make a mistake and they say
let's go ahead and take that pawn right
here
absolutely take that pawn nothing to see
here
definitely poisoned if they take it you
are definitely going to win the game so
that's
the lore trap hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video i feel like the more that you
see these types of
videos it'll just give you a better eye
on how you can
train your mind to start to look at
things and see how you can
develop your pieces so that you can have
a strong attack and see where the
weaknesses are
in this case you can definitely see it
is this d file so if you can get your
rook over here
uh and all the escape squares for the
king start to get
taken out of the game you really have a
strong attack so thank you guys so much
for watching the video and i will see
you guys in the next one